[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily what
to expect for the upcoming trial for
former theranos ceo
elizabeth holmes the questions potential
journals will be asked
about the alleged multi-million dollars
in fraud and long-time friend of robert
durst is back on the stand
how the hostile witness is responding to
questions as the real estate heir has
problems with his hearing
in court
plus jury selection is underway in
colorado for the trial of a father
accused of murdering his own son
why dylan redwine's mother is still in
shock over the loss of her 13 year old
i just didn't think mark had that in him
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
over the next month a jury will decide
whether there's enough evidence to prove
a colorado man
murdered his son dylan redwine law and
crimes angenette levy spoke with dylan's
mother
and tells us what helped with the
investigation
yeah brian opening statements are
expected in mark redwine's trial early
next week dylan redwine's mother has
been waiting
nearly nine years for some level of
accountability
in her son's murder just gotta check you
okay mark
july 2017 police put mark redwine in
handcuffs on the ground
as he's taken into custody for the
murder of his son dylan
years prior they said that they had a a
warrant for murder second
for you i'm sorry i have no idea what
that's about
dylan vanished over thanksgiving weekend
in 2012. he was on a court-ordered visit
with his father
unfortunately he was forced to go
because of the judge's decision
in retrospect i never would have put him
on that plane obviously if i would have
known then what i know now
elaine hall is dylan's mother dylan was
last seen
on a surveillance photo from a walmart
with his father
the community searched tirelessly for
dylan elaine hall said mark redwine was
conspicuously absent
he wasn't active in anything over the
months that we've searched for dylan
he wouldn't talk to anybody he was
very evasive you know he acted like
nothing was wrong in 2013 elaine hall
and mark redwine appeared on dr phil
mark redwine said this
about his son's disappearance i didn't
lose dylan elaine
how ben why is he gone well that you
know that's a question we all
have to ask but nobody's going to ask
prosecutors say dylan's blood was found
in his father's
home his remains found less than 10
miles away
evidence from cadaver dogs will be
presented at trial
after the role of the cadaver dogs you
know we feel that was a critical part of
the investigation as well
the cadaver dogs present strong evidence
placing a cadaver in mr redwater's home
and cadaver scent on his clothing as
well as cadaver scent
in his truck prospective jurors are
being told part of the evidence in the
case
involves redwine engaged in an act with
fecal matter
which isn't illegal but may be offensive
to some
over a year prior to november 2012 dylan
found several compromising personal
photographs
of his father on his father's computer
no one has ever seen
or heard dylan confront his father with
these photographs
dylan's family simply wants answers
i'd like to hear the truth i wish the
truth would come out
prosecutors claimed in the indictment
that dylan may have been planning to
confront his father
over the photos of him dressed as a
woman and involved in some type of
activity with fecal matter i asked
elaine hall
about whether or not her husband her
ex-husband now had ever
dressed as a woman or done anything else
like that and she said she was not aware
of any such
thing during their marriage brian
thanks angela joining us today is civil
rights attorney katie smith and terry
austin
kate blood cadaver dogs and a child's
remains found miles from the father's
home
what kind of defense could be raised
here
well brian it's tough the facts seem to
be very
difficult in terms of analyzing it from
the defense's perspective
but the defense attorney's best friend
is always
the burden of proof remember it's the
prosecution that bears
the heavy burden of proving beyond a
reasonable doubt and while they don't
have to prove motive
motive is always very important but the
defense needs to be careful because this
motive that they're mounting
is a slippery slope and you don't want
to get into too many damaging factual
details
that might move the jury to dislike the
defendant
so this is going to be a tough one and
we want to watch out to see what angle
they choose
makes sense terry jury questionnaires
often give us an
insight into a trial what do you expect
from this case based on the questions
well i think that the insight is it's
going to be a very
interesting case it was a very short
questionnaire it had standard questions
like
have you ever been the victim of a crime
but one of the questions
said you might see a photograph that has
fecal matter in it and if that is
introduced
you will be told that it cannot go to
the defendant's character and whether or
not the jury
can actually follow those instructions
in my opinion brian
that cannot be erased from a juror's
mind and i think that
the judge should have already decided
whether that's going to come in or
not come in because it will be
prejudicial and i don't think it's
that probative unless they really can
show it went to intent
i mean when they show it a trial i don't
think it's going to be able to
go from my mind when we see it but we'll
see and janet
what else has mark redwine said in the
past about dylan's disappearance
you know he has always denied any
involvement in his son's disappearance
and back on that dr phil episode that we
showed you from 2013 he suggested that
some
how dylan may have been abducted
apparently dylan was supposed to go to a
friend's home later that day
he also mentioned something about a
mailman seeing dylan later that day
after he had gone to work so it'll be
interesting to see uh what the defense
says at trial
if anything if as we know they don't
have to put on a case yeah
we'll see how this plays out thank you
everyone still ahead on lawn crime daily
the upcoming trial for former ethereum
ceo elizabeth holmes
why more than 100 questions for
potential jurors are being scrapped
but first mayonnaise real estate air
robert durst has a new look
as an old friend takes the witness stand
see that more fireworks between the
lawyers
[Music]
next
[Music]
welcome back one of robert durst's
friends is back on the witness stand
after delay in court due to a health
incident involving the millionaire real
estate heir
robert durst appeared in court on
wednesday with a shaved head
the scar from when the doctors inserted
a shunt into his head in 2017
was visible along with his catheter
durst is accused of murdering his best
friend susan berman in december 2000.
prosecutors say durst believed berman
threatened to go to the authorities with
information about durst's missing wife
kathy the defendant's friend doug oliver
began testifying last week
and was declared a hostile witness for
the state the direct line of questioning
was paused
because durst was hospitalized on
wednesday oliver continued to deny he
ever made the comment that kathy durst
was sold into white slavery
you at times said mr oliver that if you
said it
you said it because you were trying to
be quote funny unquote
yes i believe i said that so can you
tell me
what would be funny about that i'm sorry
can you explain what would be
funny nothing's funny about it well
so mr oliver when you said if you said
it you were trying to be funny can you
explain what you would have meant by
that
i can't explain what i meant by it
would you agree that that would be an
inappropriate and uncooperative comment
i no
can you explain then if your
let me back up is your position that you
believe that kathy durst was sold into
white slavery because of a cocaine
problem
no where did you even come up with that
comment
i believe that the officer offered me up
certain possibilities
and i think now that i refreshed my
memory that that was one of the many he
offered up
court then took another short break due
to an issue with the defendant's hearing
aids
you can hear them beeping in the
background
hearing aids is too idea they have to be
updated
yeah i guess like your alarm and your
smoke alarm
it's always goes off at like 2 a.m and
you have to
take it down and change the batteries in
an inopportune moment
so i think that may be what we're
grappling with
prosecutor john lewin played a recorded
phone call between
oliver and the defendant in jail on the
call oliver says he's upset about
another of dirt's friends
telling authorities that the defendant
admitted to murdering berman
and talking about the trial the thing
that really upset me
is nick i just can't believe that guys
here we go now the thing that really
upset me about this
a little i know about what's going on is
nick i just can't believe nick
you know just just can't believe what
i just can't believe he did what he did
that's all who cares
who again
the next two lines are mr durst says
yeah well
it upset me too and then you say you
know as a friend
you've had a chance to review that
previously correct mr oliver
i just read it and isn't it true mr
oliver that what you meant
by this statement is that you were
voicing your
disprovable your disapproval with nick
chavin for having
communicated bob's confession to
investigators
uh yes
back with us to civil rights attorney
katie smith and terry austin
terry more fireworks as oliver testified
lewin seemed in control of the court
but he seemed to struggle to get oliver
to admit to opinion questions
what do you think well i think you're
right brian
there were more fireworks indeed i mean
he wasted a lot of time
trying to talk about opinion questions
and he wasted a lot of time
talking about small points i know he
wants to establish
that oliver was biased and he would do
anything for durst
but he actually as we just saw that
question about
kathy being sold into white slavery
because of a cane problem
he talked about that cocaine problem and
the white slavery issue and was it funny
for the longest amount of time actually
i do
think that the judge did well today that
he tried to pull
lewin in he told loin on more than one
occasion
look you've made your point move on now
and so
i think it might be a little late to do
that but he is at least trying to reign
lewin in a little bit and not let him
take over the entire court
katie to terry's point there's a lot of
bickering back and forth but the judge
seems to
sometimes look to lewin for case law how
do you think the jury is viewing all of
this
you know juries tend to really get tired
of that very quickly
the inner play between the judges and
the attorneys
tends to waste the jurors time at least
i know i've spoken to jurors and they
say that so
i don't think that they credit that too
much and oftentimes they tend to glaze
out because really that stuff they're
going to be later told
they can't even consider when they're
considering evidence in the case
so i think that there tends to be a
level of fatigue that the jurors feel
about that type of behavior
yeah and this is going to be quite the
long case as expected to last a month so
we'll see how that fatigue or if that
fatigue settles in over time
coming up on law and crime daily the
defense gets their turn
to question doug oliver plus the trial
of theranos ceo elizabeth holmes is
coming up
why her defense attorney is calling a
judge's changes to a potential jury
questionnaire
disastrous
[Music]
welcome back defense attorneys for
robert durst had the opportunity
to ask his longtime friend questions but
it didn't exactly begin
as planned may i see if we've got the
clip that i want to play here
yes know i would just request that when
mr daguerreon wants to take
mr oliver on as his own witness as he
has indicated to me before
he wants to do that he let court and
counsel know
that at this point in time he's taking
him on as his own witnesses that will
change the dynamic of questioning
[Music]
i have a right to cross-examine that's
not what you don't
actually well then talk about it i don't
have a right to cross-examine the
witness
you have the right to examine the
witness but you may not need
then the defense asked doug oliver more
about the defendant's friend
who allegedly heard durst confess to the
murder of susan berman
did you say that you tell mr lewin in
the same conversation that he just
referred to
that you didn't think that nick chavin
was truthful
yes in fact did you say several times
that you couldn't believe
what nick said yes
meaning that you couldn't believe nick
because he's not credible
yes you know nick chavin or knew nick
chavin didn't you
yes do you have an opinion about whether
he's a truthful person
i thought he had a tendency to
exaggerate things
in fact did you have you told mr lewin
and told others that you thought nick
was hanging around bob just for the
money
i did say that
these were a series of leading questions
i just the court had said i haven't
objected yet but
thank you
that's one of those speaking
non-objections yeah i mean what do i do
it's not a check
it's not a speaking objection no thank
you
back with us the civil rights attorney
katie smith and co-host terry austin
terry the defense seemed shocked as was
i even after researching
uh the rule that the court put out there
did the defense's unfamiliar
unfamiliarity sorry with cali law affect
the
listen there is no question that lewin
knows california law
better than de guern and even better
than the judge and the judge said that
he says
listen you might know the law better
than i do but on this point
i think de gern had a good point he
wanted to do
his cross-examination and he wanted to
do leading questions
but there had been a motion about that
and i think that lewin was correct the
judge had already ruled
that because oliver was designated
as a hostile witness for the prosecution
when it goes
back and the defense is asking questions
at that point
he cannot cross and lead the witness
because
he's really a friendly witness for the
defense so
it made sense even though it's something
that we're not accustomed to seeing
and i have to give loan credit for
knowing the details and the
ins and outs of the california law yeah
it's got to be one of those cali laws
that doesn't make sense to us new york
attorneys because that would
just make it that i don't know you maybe
don't cross-examine anyone because all
the witnesses are hostile for the
prosecution but
we'll see let's be honest katie oliver
isn't giving up his friends though so
does it really matter
what he says on cross or did the defense
get something out of him that helped
brian there were a few good nuggets on
their face right the stuff that he said
about shaven i thought were
particularly helpful but the jury
immediately like most of us will decide
whether or not we think that this person
is biased
and so if someone is a longtime friend
like oliver
is we tend to look at that testimony
with a grain of salt because obviously
he doesn't want to give up his friend
and he might be saying whatever he can
to help his friend out so i think it
really depends
on what the jury decides about that very
issue
about whether or not they're going to
even credit the stuff that he said
absolutely makes sense thank you both
when we come back fraud lies in
misrepresentations
the charges against former ceo elizabeth
holmes and her attorney's concerns
about finding unbiased jurors
welcome back tensions are heating up as
the trial for the former ceo of theranos
elizabeth holmes nears holmes is accused
of defrauding investors of millions
and scamming doctors and patients
what do you dream for that less people
have to say goodbye too soon to people
they love that was elizabeth holmes in
an hbo documentary talking about
theranos the company she founded in 2003
it was promoted as a way to
revolutionize medical lab testing
but federal prosecutors say it was a
scam a grand jury indicted holmes and
theranos ceo
ramesh sanibawani in 2018 on 11 charges
of wire fraud and conspiracy
to commit wire fraud they're both
pleading not guilty and holmes is slated
to go to trial first on august 31st
at a hearing on tuesday the judge
granted holmes permission to nurse her
newborn child
during breaks in court now attorneys are
taking aim with a proposed jury
questionnaire
the 46-page document asks prospective
jurors about their news habits
and if they follow any of more than a
dozen journalists including law and
crime investigative reporter
adam classfeld they're also asked if
they've seen any of the eight specials
on homes
including the inventor out for blood in
silicon valley
you all are part of something that is
going to change our world
what higher purpose is there elizabeth
came to me
and she described her idea
[Music]
it's impossible physically the company
claimed it would transform blood testing
using a few drops of blood in a
so-called nanotater
holm's trial has been delayed numerous
times because the pandemic and her
pregnancy
it's scheduled to last 13 weeks while
the is warning prospective jurors
it could last longer
katie major trials in the media at least
i think are here to stay
are these questioners too long as a
prosecution argues or just a reflection
of the times
brian you have to always strike that
balance right because you don't want
people who've consumed
too much media around these specific
issues so for example i think whether
people have watched the hbo specials and
already made up their minds about this
case
that would be important to ask but
whether you're essentially asking people
in this state in this questionnaire
whether they've consumed really any type
of media it's extremely broad
and you're allowing either side to
really try to exclude people that they
want dismiss
on cause instead of using peremptory
challenges which is a really big deal
when you're doing jury selection
so i think this goes a little far and we
need to be very judicious in how we use
these questionnaires
yeah definitely interesting to see how
that judge finds that balance maybe
scaling back a little
for the defense is asking terry our very
own adam class held his name in the
questionnaire
as someone the defense wants to know if
the jurors have listened to
are there any other questions that
jumped out at you
you know it's interesting they did ask
questions about whether or not
the jurors were on medication whether or
not they'd ever posted on social media
but i think the part about the
questionnaire that the defense
made and made so long was repetitive
questions
argumentative questions but they were
mostly about the media and i think
the prosecution thought to themselves
well this is just too much and this
should not be allowed and the judge
actually did cut back a little bit and
said that because it was so repetitive
we're not going to allow this so i
definitely think that you have to get
into the details of a case i think you
have to make sure that the jurors are
going to be
fair they're not going to be biased but
i think jurors
can't be asked over and over specifics
about
the name of particular publications and
to your point the name of particular
artists or
you know writers who are working in
those publications
because frankly jurors aren't going to
remember that kind of detail
anyway and that is actually one of the
arguments that the prosecution made that
they have
read these articles but they're not
going to remember all of those details
anyway
now terry quick question could this all
be solved by changing venue maybe a
different state
i think everybody's heard about this but
particularly california so maybe who
knows if it could help
all right we'll see thanks for joining
us here at long crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you